nice to meet you too oh no you know a
little bit my kids got me sick
oh okay I got my kids six babies oh well
I love your shoes I like color
hey shut up the movie welcome is really
funny thank you
what was it like for you to get back
into character Gomorrah just find it
easiest time all oh yeah I think excuse
me I think it's always easy it's easier
for me I should get back into a
character that I've done before
yeah because it all its I could just
have the dust things off and and really
always trust your director and and
follow his lead and I'm one of those
actors I like to follow my directors
lead but it's always fun the makeup
process is not it was not fun but we
made progress the second time around
because the first time was five hours
and this time it was four
yeah a little bit but haha I have to be
half away exactly what's it like being
on blacking even with Chris Pratt if
he's funny he's super funny it's just
great we all get along and and chris is
really funny so he's always entertaining
us and um and Dave is such a gentle
giant he's very soft-spoken so you're
always going what fuzzy with Brazil had
really and and then Karen and Palm it
was wonderful to have like women on set
you know yeah sometimes being the only
girl can get quite lonely even though
men tend to take care of you and the
baby you a lot but it's always good to
have like girl power
oh yeah I want to do it yeah definitely
a lot of 80s references and movie if you
could pick one eighties neighbor that
you like star in what would it be
The Goonies he wouldn't hire me I'm too
old right now
I would have I would have loved you been
in the Goonies in six years that she's
died in colombiana always and please Pat
there are talks of a sequel potentially
however you meet you yeah is that
something you'd be keen on doing you
don't have to send a message to the
Busan he's a producer of it please I
thought maybe I made it I'm from your
Corvus on that we everybody's asking for
: Vienna - yes I would love to do it
love on so it's literally one of my
favorite movies I loved I'd love it but
also we were talking about the makeup
process earlier for Gomorrah so you've
done Green now and you look blue and
Avatar what's your next color I would
love to be in this color fishes okay um
but I did I did a movie in between space
movies called live by night and I also
did another one called
I killed Ryan so it's a very small
independent movie based on a graphic
novel and and I shot it in Ireland last
year I had a blast
but um you know what I would be any
color yeah as long as I get to be a part
of like great movies and inspire people
especially the younger audience it's
like why not yeah and you know your
co-star current obviously shaved I had a
theory of this really is there anything
that you wouldn't do for role or you
pretty much gave for anything not
everything I wouldn't do i wouldn't do
just anything for a role as i didn't
physically would shave - I was I totally
would but I wouldn't like kind of finger
for a role no no I don't think it
depends on what role okay just just
disappointing yeah person so you've
obviously got to adorable twin boys
thank you yeah I had three boys yeah
well yeah yeah yeah oh here we get there
I jumped again there are we there for
those twin fever in the air at the
moment they George Clooney and mal
expecting twins and because interesting
as well do you have any advice for them
provoke their copycat universe by the
way um actually routine it will save
your sanity it will save your marriage
it's just keeping your twins on a
routine is all probably the best thing
that you can ever do for them primarily
and then for yourself
so bath time less or in
our sleep time within our eating at a
certain hour and for you to do it for
them to do it always together that way
they learn to be around each other even
when one wants to do something and the
other one doesn't
they still have to be with each other
and that that has been our like our
secret weapon our secret recipe
everything go back to the main page
Gamora and her sister know obviously
have this rivalry and in this movie
every day love each other what are you
talking about I get along just fine ever
bow ah yes like sister yeah growing up
with your sisters did you ever have any
competitiveness between you we were I
mean competitive like as far as like
healthy sisterhood go into increase of
us no we thought I mean but we would
fight over over jeans over dolls over
games over mommies attention over who
would ride shotgun over who would clean
the dishes like um I was very possessive
with my sisters so whenever they brought
over a best friend
I was so mean to those girls of I would
be so jealous
so um it was just great when we turned
you know when we were like in our 20s
and we sort of like grew out of it but
we're actually writing a sitcom based on
our our lives growing up together as
young adults in New York because at one
point when we were like in our early 20s
we all lived together in a three-bedroom
apartment and my sister was a single mom
of a little girl so um those we were
still fighting oh my god it was Trey
like decisive thing about the wonders
but hahaha oh that's what's great thank
you so much they hear I was going to
love you talking to you bye guys Bassem
thank you I'll be right